on en débat beaucoup depuis l'assassinât
de sa mue et patti par un terroriste au
motif qu'il avait montré des caricatures
de mahomet à des élèves mais c'est quoi
la liberté d'expression la liberté
d'expression est un héritage de la
révolution française elle est inscrite
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 c'est une liberté
fondamentale de chaque citoyen l'article
11 stipule la libre communication des
pensées et des opinions est un des
droits les plus précieux de l'homme tout
citoyen peut donc parler écrire imprimer
librement sauf à répondre de l'abus de
cette liberté dans les cas déterminés
par la loi
pour le constitutionnaliste jean
philippe desrosiers c'est la liberté la
plus fondamentale car elle conditionne
l'exercice d'autres droits démocratiques
c'est à partir d'une expression libre
ont abouti à la fabrication de la loi
par le peuple souverain et donc à la
démocratie aujourd'hui la liberté
d'expression est toujours un droit
inaliénable pour chaque citoyen français
car la déclaration des droits de l'homme
de 1789 est inscrite dans le bloc de
constitutionnalité
c'est à dire qu'elle est située au
sommet de la hiérarchie des normes au
même titre que la constitution du 4
octobre 1958 ou encore de la charte de
l'environnement de 2004 mais la liberté
d'expression n'est pas une liberté
absolue comme toutes les libertés ces
abus peuvent être sanctionnée dans la
mesure où elles nuisent à autrui
pendant longtemps les auteurs éditeurs
journalistes se sont battus pour
défendre leur liberté d'expression
contre la censure de l'état mais
aujourd'hui ce sont parfois les abus de
cette liberté qu'il faut combattre
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux les
supports d'expression se sont
démultipliés grâce aux réseaux sociaux
et avec eux les abus de l'exercice de
cette liberté comme l'ain
roux la diffamation ces limites à la
liberté d'expression sont fixés dans une
loi qui fêtera bientôt ses 140 ans la
loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la liberté de
la presse
cette loi sanctionne les propos écrits
ou oraux comme la provocation au crime
au délit comme l'injure ou comme la
diffamation tenue dans un cadre public
à l'époque les injures ce solde est
souvent par des duels
aujourd'hui on les amène devant le
tribunal pénal et elles se soldent par
des amendes ou même des peines de prison
[Musique]